[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY PRIES: We're
here today to talk
about Cloud costs and
reporting on them,
and hopefully aligning
that with what
services you're delivering
for your business
or your customers.
The agenda today-- so I need
to go over some things with you
to make sure that everyone
understands the building
blocks that we have,
organizational options
about how we set up
our GCP infrastructure.
Then we'll go over what's
available for tooling out
there.
And then we can get
into some strategies
towards the end of
the presentation
about how we can apply those
and help you line up your costs.
So I'm Jeremy, director of
Cloud infrastructure for Agosto.
Agosto's been a GCP partner
for at least 10 years
since G Suite was
first released.
Agosto started the Google
practice there and divested
the rest of the business.
And since then, we've
been strictly focused
on Google technologies.
So my role in
infrastructure is to do
everything that's not
app dev or G Suite
or Chrome for the most part.
So we help customers
all day, everyday
with aligning their costs
and identity management
and implementing these
various architectures.
So I wanted to start out
with a couple of things
that I observe as I
work with our customers.
First of all is that your
consumption-- everyone
is in their own state, right?
But consumption starts at
zero, of course, and ramps up.
So I'm trying to
get to the point
that it can surprise
you sometimes.
Organizations want
predictable costs.
They want to know, hey, what's
my bill going to be next month?
But Cloud isn't really
designed for that, ultimately.
Because you pay
for what you use.
It's not supposed to
be a predictable model.
But our companies
still want predictable.
So we try to meet in the middle
and estimate and use reporting
tools.
And I put the quote down on
the bottom in number two there.
Get this under
control is something
that we hear from our customers.
Maybe you get started and
you fly under the radar
for your consumption.
And then eventually,
you hit dollar amount
that raises some alarms
within your organization.
And hopefully,
before we get there,
we can have some
reporting that shows you,
why did we get there?
Just because it doesn't mean
our costs are out of control,
is what the point
I'm trying to say is.
Sometimes customers just
haven't spent any time
on reflecting back to their
business outside of the IT
organization, or whoever is
responsible for primary GCP
administration.
Sometimes they just haven't
shared the right information
with the business.
So that's a lot
of why we're here.
Point three.
Is there are a lot of different
people in your organization
who may be interested
in this data
and they need different stuff?
App owners' business
units need different stuff
than the finance department.
Then maybe if you have central
IT-- not everybody does--
but maybe if you have central
IT, they need different things.
And executives want
their view as well.
A high-level way
of looking at it.
So we'll cover tool
sets that'll help us
for all of those
different people
and build out a strategy
that is proactive here.
So let's go through
some definitions.
Hopefully, this isn't
too basic for you.
But I want to make sure
everybody understood.
In GCP, we have orgs.
So that's your Agosto.com,
for example, for me.
We can have any number of them.
It's a DNS domain.
They're free.
Sometimes we want more than one.
Sometimes we want
some isolated for GCP.
Sometimes we want it to
be our primary domain.
But we have the
concept of an org node.
Inside that used to be projects.
And projects have resources.
So resources being Compute
Engine, VMs, Kubernetes, Cloud
SQL, any of your
different technologies.
And in between,
there are folders.
So folders are not super old.
They haven't existed forever.
And we're constantly
finding new ways to do them.
And folders are something that's
been really helpful for us
recently.
So simply, projects can reside
in folders but don't have to.
So I put a couple
of data points here.
I think Google, when
they designed them,
would primarily tell you
that folders are there
for IAM enforcement point.
So you can set up some
permissions on a folder.
And then every
project you create
in there will inherit
those permissions,
a lot like a folder structure
you'd find on a file system.
But we're finding
other ways to use them
in terms of reporting as well.
Projects are completely
separate from each other
but report into the same folder.
Resources, then, are part of
the project, like I mentioned.
And then important point
is that you don't have
to have a project in a folder.
So if you stand up an
empty org node in GCP--
I'm sure plenty of you
have seen this-- hey,
I don't have a folder.
I don't have to
have them at all.
So then outside of all of
that tree that I just drew,
there are billing accounts.
A lot of you may know
your billing account
as being something in your org.
But it doesn't have
to be in there.
And you don't have to have
just one billing account.
But a billing account
is simply a bill.
It's going to come
as its own bill.
And the bill is
linked to projects.
And so you can default things.
But generally speaking,
the bill has projects.
The billing account has
projects associated with it.
And you can disable billing on
the individual project level
as well.
Important to note that
billing accounts also have
their own IAM permission sets.
So you can blend in
some folder permissions,
along with billing
account permissions,
to come up with a
strategy to make
sure the right people
are assigning billing
to the right place.
Switching gears a little bit.
Our labels.
When we come into cost
reporting, a lot of people
jump to the concept
of labels immediately.
It's not our only strategy,
but it's a super important one.
So you can label lots of things.
For the purposes of
billing information,
you link them with a resource.
So at the simplest
level, a GCE VM
has a key value
pair that you could
assign to it that is the label.
So we can have a
bunch of them per.
You can have a permissions set.
So 64 labels per resource.
Really billing
specific related here.
I have a couple example
use cases in a minute.
But labels based on
a team or cost center
are a super common way
to report on billing.
That's one of the
default ways that Google
might look at them being used.
Here you go.
A laundry list of things
that can be labeled.
Probably not complete.
But think of anything that
bills, that generates costs,
has a SKU associated with
them, can be labeled.
I think it's
probably important--
I don't think I cover
it in the next slide--
I think it's probably important
to tell you that projects
can be labeled as well.
That's a newer functionality.
But that label doesn't show
up in the billing data.
So it's not like an
inheritance thing.
I've seen people assume that,
hey, I labeled my project,
and I might use that for
various automation reasons.
But I can't look at that
label for the project.
When I look at billing for,
say, GCE, in the instance,
it wouldn't inherit the label.
So you'll see stuff--
VM instances, images, persistent
disks, snapshots, BigQuery,
even individual
queries, Cloud SQL--
all the major products
have support for labels.
Here's some example things that
you might apply to a resource.
An owner, a team, an
environment, production,
dev test, whatever.
An app name, server
type, OS image.
And so their use case
isn't strictly for billing.
You might apply some
kind of security policy
or some kind of
automation to that.
You might use it for
scripting to find
all the VMs with a certain label
and do something with them.
But for the purposes
of this conversation,
they're there to
help you report.
GKE is super popular.
This is a little
bit in the weeds.
But I wanted to bring
it up, because I
think it's important, coming
up here in a little bit,
to understand that
GKE has name spaces.
And it can assign
labels to them.
But in the billing data, I
can't see the labels outside
of the cluster.
So you assign the labels
from a billing perspective
at the cluster level only.
So you'll see, if you
have a bunch of stuff
in a rather large
cluster, it'll look
like a jumbled-together mix.
Multi-tenant people
in particular
will need to come up
with a strategy for how
to deal with this.
So that sets the stage
of the different building
blocks we have within GCP.
So now I wanted to go over,
what kind of data can we get at?
So at the billing account level,
we can export into BigQuery.
And I'd assume everyone's
familiar BigQuery.
It's a platform-based
database that's ready to use.
We can go into our
billing account settings
and set up to
export billing data
to whatever data set we choose.
So if we were to have more
than one billing account,
we would end up with
separate data sets.
They wouldn't be mixed together.
At a minimum, they'd
be in separate tables.
So I wanted to give you a little
bit about what's in there.
Because it becomes really
important to understand that.
BigQuery billing data is--
so let me back up.
Your billing account, then,
at the end of every month,
you'll receive a CSV file.
And a CSV file will have--
for every project, you'll have
every single SKU that you're
using and the number of units
in the bill in the dollar
amount associated with that.
So that's at this really
high-level glossy view.
The BigQuery data is not that.
The BigQuery data trickles
in throughout the month,
throughout the day.
You'll have, I don't
know, thousands of rows
that show up in there throughout
the month as you're reporting.
So I'll go over a few of
the different items that
are in there.
So there'll be a usage start and
end time for every single row.
It'll associate with
an invoice month.
So the invoice months
and BigQuery do add up.
If you do sums on it, and
you look at the month,
it will add up to exactly down
to the penny, to your bill.
A project, of course, is
associated with it, a service.
So Compute Engine is a service.
Cloud storage is a service.
Within a service are SKUs.
So persistent disk, for
example, is a SKU that
falls within Compute Engine.
So I included a
link to the SKUs.
But it's a crazy number of SKUs.
Now we talked about folders.
Folder data shows up in BigQuery
in the ancestry numbers.
That's what the column's called.
That will be in the
form of an organization.
And then separated by slash
will be your full folder path.
So you could have up to
five things in there,
with four folders inside an org.
Important to note,
those are numbers.
If you look inside
the GCP console
and you explore your
resources, you'll see numbers.
It's an identifier number.
And you'll need to
look that up if you're
doing any reporting on it.
So that data's in there.
Labels.
Key value pairs are nested
data that's in there.
Location, as in zone,
region, country,
whatever the resource is,
whatever the appropriate thing
is there.
Cloud storage might show up
as a country, versus a VM
would show up in a
region and a zone.
And then usage costs and credit.
So it'll have a unit.
It'll have dollar
amount for the cost.
And then credits are
important to note
as you're looking through
whatever billing reporting
data you're looking at is.
The credits are-- sustained
use discount will show up
as a credit, for example.
So a SKU has a list price.
And it'll multiply
by-- it ends up
multiplying by the second
throughout the month.
And then halfway
through the month,
you start to receive a discount.
That discount shows up
as the form of a credit.
So you have to add them
together to get your total cost
for that particular row.
So this conversation is
important to bring up.
The main tool you have
to look at this data
is right in your console.
Console billing reports.
No setup required.
You just log in and can
see your billing reports.
I'm sure all of you have.
You can view this data by a
number of different things.
So you can filter by date,
range, project, product SKU,
labels, all the above.
One thing that's not
in there are folders.
I don't know if
that's coming or not.
But it's not in there today.
So it's a really detailed
way to look at something.
You could use this
reporting to, say,
how much paid OS
licenses do I have
for last month in this
project, for example?
That's in there by
looking at the SKU data.
And you also can group
that data together.
So you could look at, hey, how
much did that project cost?
Pretty much, you can explore
your data in any number of ways
that you want to.
So super powerful tool
and really good for GCP
administrators to use.
Our experience has been
that, as we get away
from people who use
GCP on a daily basis,
the less they really
would want to go in there
and navigate into that.
And that's where we
use separate reporting
for those kind of personas.
So your GCP admins are going
to be totally fine figuring out
whatever they need to.
One of my primary ways to
look when questions come up
is to just log into the billing
reporting and go look at it.
So that's the base
to build off of.
From a product perspective, Data
Studio is included with GCP.
Data Studio connects to
BigQuery and numerous other data
sources.
But for the purpose of this,
it'll hook up to BigQuery.
And you can use it as
a visualization tool.
And the only thing you
pay for is whatever
BigQuery costs that you have.
And so BigQuery is
super cheap for when
you're just looking at small
data sets like billing data.
You're probably looking at
usage in the pennies range.
So it flies under
the radar there.
And it pretty much ends up being
a free reporting tool for you
to build off of.
I think another important
thing to say about Data Studio
is you can feed it a table.
And you can use the UI
to design your queries.
And you don't end up knowing
you're making queries.
You don't have to sit
down and write SQL here
to make this happen.
At the end, I have a
link to a GitHub repo
that'll help you
with some queries.
And we use a view to
drive our Data Studio,
because we want to expose
folder data by name.
So I include a little
helper table there.
That helper table, then, has
your folder numbers and names.
And it does that link together
and presents the right folder
name for you.
And then it includes
some scripts
on how to gather that data G
Cloud and PowerShell scripts
that'll help you do that.
When we're talking
about visualization,
there's no reason to say that it
has to be Data Studio, though.
If your organization
has whatever other data
presentation visualization
tools, that's cool.
Many of them hook
up to BigQuery.
It's very popular.
So most of the major
players already
have support for BigQuery.
So you don't have to
necessarily use Data Studio.
But this is the one
included in GCP.
And it's the one we go with.
And it also has Google
Auth built right into it.
So we can control
who can see it.
And we can share
it, just like we're
used to with our businesses
driven by G Suite.
Brand-new-- I think it might
have been formally released
yesterday--
it was in beta form,
and we've been using it
for quite a while, is the
Sheets data connector.
So it's Google Sheets data
connector for BigQuery.
And we can write a
query, plop it in,
just like you see in
the screenshot there.
And then we have our accounting
people run their own queries.
And so they can pull up a month
and summarize the data however
we decided in the query.
And then they have
immediate access
to that at the end of the month.
For accounting people, they seem
to really love tabular data.
So everything we've said
here doesn't address the fact
that people want--
how much did that VM cost me?
It's something that
comes up all the time.
So the main way I would
tell you to probably do that
would be to label your VM.
I think it's way faster than
what I'm showing you here.
But I wanted to tell
you that the spot
to see usage data
per VM is set up
inside each project
in Compute Engine.
And it'll export to CSV only.
So we could pull together
our own reporting
if we wanted to that'll go
look at the units of the data
that we see here.
So it'll be a whole bunch of
rows inside the sheet, one
for each object.
And it'll show you, how
many seconds did I use?
How many byte seconds
of RAM did I use?
Or how many seconds
of CPU did I use?
And it can use that at
the end of the month
to calculate how
much that VM costs.
Now there's no tool
sets beyond that
I'm aware of to help you
actually figure that cost out.
So it's a little
bit painful to do.
You'd need to look up the
SKU and do the math yourself.
Not the end of the world,
but it's a bit of work.
And that's why I'd recommend,
if you do need that data,
to go into a labeling
strategy to try to achieve it.
Or, most of our customers
who are talking about that,
I usually turn the conversation
around a little bit
and try to focus less
on individual instances
and focus more on services.
So that the concept of the VM
being a permanent thing that
exists forever--
it's not fluid.
And so it's much
more a cloud-like
to look at things as
a dynamic resource.
The VMs come and go.
And they're all part of
delivering whatever service.
And that's more of the level
we want to look at things.
So important to note.
Sometimes people ask,
what network traffic
did I have per VM?
And that's a legit need that
you have, and it's in there.
You can look at the
inter and intra zone.
And you can also look at
inbound load balancers as well.
Super cool.
I haven't had much chance
to play with this here.
I wanted to bring it up.
Probably a bit of a hike,
but there's a session
immediately after
this one in Moscone
on this specific feature
that was just released.
So GKE can dump to
BigQuery usage data.
So in the same data set, we
could take a GKE cluster,
and then we could
look at namespaces.
And we mentioned
namespaces earlier there.
We can look at namespaces or
labels inside the GKE cluster.
And we can join that
with the billing data.
So it's just performance data.
But we join that with
the billing data.
And you can see here Google
provided an example Data Studio
report.
And they do have
a bunch of example
Data Studio stuff to
go look at out there,
if you do some searches.
And maybe on GitHub, I
can include some links.
I haven't done that yet,
but I could probably
do that to direct you
right to the report
so you don't have to
hunt around for them.
But this seems like it's
going to be a really cool way
to build up some additional
reporting that we didn't have.
This was first
announced, I think,
late January in a blog post.
So moving on to some strategies.
I feel like at this point,
we've laid the groundwork.
You understand the
building blocks
that we have on
how to organize GCP
and then where we
can get to our data.
So what do we do with that now?
How do we set it up?
With customers, every
time they come to us,
want to know how many
orgs should I have?
How many projects should I have?
Should I do everything
in one big GKE cluster?
All those sort of questions.
And I'm not going to tell
you that we have the answers,
because it's super situational.
Customers want best practices.
And I think we're at the
point where we can say
we have some best practices.
But it's not going to be a
recipe for you that tells you
exactly what you need.
It's more of some
general guidance.
And everybody's just so unique.
And the platform's
so vast that there's
no way to tell you exactly
how you should do that.
So I want to come back to this.
So consumption builds over time.
So let's proactively build
some reports for our people
so that they don't become
surprised by the bill.
So that we don't
have people who think
our costs aren't under control.
The only people I think of that
I describe as not under control
are people who have lost
resources out there.
And that's a real thing.
VM sprawl is what we
used to call it back
in the day in the VMware
world, where we've stranded
maybe disk files, for example.
Persistent disks.
I ran into a customer the
other day, $12,000 a month
worth of SSDs, sitting
there detached.
That stuff happens.
Those are the people that
I think are under control.
Besides that, it's
usually a visibility issue
about, we don't
really know what's
going on out there, because
you haven't really showed me
much data.
And I get a bill at
the end of the month,
and it's x number of dollars.
And it's not where
I want it to be.
And I'm kind of frustrated
that I have to pay that.
So it's important that
our different personas
there on the right have
their view of the world
and can explore that data.
And I think it helps
build a lot of trust.
So we've presented two main ways
to summarize that data, labels
and folders.
So I laid out a couple of
points related to each.
The labels are super flexible.
They're built into all the
existing reporting tools.
They're very natural to use.
The main concern
we have with people
who go in with an
only labeling strategy
is that you have to be detailed
enough to get the labels there.
It's that easy.
And if you're doing manual
processes, it gets missed.
So from a process
perspective, we always say,
we need to automate that.
We need to provision
with Terraform.
We need to use any kind
of automation tool,
or people forget things,
especially the little
tiny details like that.
Folders are a way to
automatically summarize
the data.
As long as projects get
put in the right place,
they're going to be
reported on correctly.
But the concern sometimes,
where they don't work out,
is IAM rules are not in line.
So there's several
reasons why you
might say that costs needs
to be spread out differently.
Because I can't have that
set of IAM rules on a folder.
It doesn't add up in the end.
So that's where
that doesn't work.
And I'll also tell you,
folders aren't super flexible.
They're are high-level roll up.
So I think the next
one goes into--
I call this enterprise.
Call it corporate.
Call it non-SaaS offerings.
So I gave an example here.
You can see, IT has a folder.
Finance has a folder.
HR has a folder.
Sales has a folder.
There are apps.
Apps as in projects
in those folders.
And it's a very quick
way to say, all right,
so someone running
systems for finance
only has project creator access
at the finance folder level.
And we have a lot of
customers who are doing this.
And then we know exactly
that that finance department
is going to end up paying the
bill for that consumption.
It allows for three
layers of folders.
I covered that earlier.
Cory, do you remember,
is it three or four?
I thought it was four.
CORY: You could do three
or four in each of them.
JEREMY PRIES: Yeah, thanks.
Thanks.
That was a typo, then.
That's what I thought.
So you can do some roll
ups if you need to.
If you need to break out
finance into individual apps,
or dev test prod, or whatever
other folders beneath that
for operational reasons,
you certainly can.
And we typically
almost always roll up
the costs into that
top-level folder.
And that's what you'll find.
All of my scripts that
are out there for,
all the queries
that are out there,
roll up to the top level.
But it's easy enough
to adjust, too.
So that's a typical
corporate environment
that's general purpose GCP,
not real focused on deploying
a specific product.
Some sample view here, or a
screenshot, of Data Studio.
So we've got a number of
folders there in that dropdown.
So that's a filter.
This is our standard report.
It'll look just
very similar to one
you can pull down from Google.
It has a date range.
It has a list of folders.
You'll see the summary dollar
amounts there on the right.
And then once you
dial in that cost,
you can see then all the
different graphics will change.
So that stuff's all super easy
to do in Data Studio, as well.
You set it up as
a filter control.
And you tell it what column
you want to filter on.
I think I forgot to
mention one thing, too.
In BigQuery, BigQuery
supports date partitioning.
And that's a way to limit
how much data we're querying.
So BigQuery is charged by
how much data you query.
That's kind of generally
how your cost is.
And so in here is,
date partitions
are filled out by the
BigQuery data export.
And this control will use that
in Data Studio to filter it.
So say you had a gig of data,
or whatever number of data,
that covered all of time.
And if you just press Search
without a filter on it,
it will scan all that data.
And you'll pay for
that whole query.
But in this case, I said
February 1 to February 28.
And that adjusted the
date partition filter.
And so I only paid for-- maybe
it's 10 meg of that data,
or whatever the number is.
It's the subset of data.
So I don't need
to pay for it all.
And it does keep
things more affordable.
Not a huge concern for most
people in their footprint
of their billing data,
because it is small enough.
But still important to note
that that's easy enough to do.
And it's built in the platform.
So why not use it and save
a little bit of money?
So that's the view.
The standard report that
you pull down from Google
has broken down by
resource, by project.
You could explore
into Compute Engine.
And you could see, for
example, how much you're
paying for a persistent disk.
There's a number of
ways to break that down.
And so here is, then,
a similar concept
to present that in
the Sheets view.
So the BigQuery
connector in Sheets.
So like I mentioned, this would
be what your finance department
uses to report back their
spend to the business,
break down those costs.
So really easy,
tabular way to do it.
And that's an example of
a way to group by folder.
There's no reason you couldn't
group by label as well,
or both.
Or both.
And it includes sample
BigQuery of what
you would put in here to
generate that as well.
I even did one that has last
month automatically calculated
for you.
So you don't need to apply that.
And it would be really easy
to just stick it in a sheet
and start using it.
So a single-tenant model.
These guys are the easiest to
make decisions for, I think.
Meaning, we have
a certain amount
of resources that are
provisioned every time we
spin up a customer.
Super obvious that we probably
need to automatically provision
that customer.
So we build some
Terraform scripts.
We separate out with IAM
dev test and prod, perhaps.
And we deploy a new
project for every customer.
And we deploy whatever
into that project
that makes the customer go.
Usually, the biggest decision
you're going to make there
is related to networking.
Kind of out of scope of this
conversation, but obviously,
it's super important.
Everybody with a
single-tenant model
always has some kind
of common ops system.
Monitoring, security systems,
those kind of things,
that it gets to be tough
to align those costs
with individual customers.
They're just a fixed fee
that our customers have.
So generally speaking, we don't
associate those costs back
to an individual,
the ops systems.
But you can see there,
individual project level
reporting is sufficient,
generally speaking, to say,
how much for customer
A to run last month,
is a very easy
thing to search on.
That's super obvious.
We do have a lot
of people who try
to fit numerous customers
into one project,
but yet still have a
single-tenant system.
And our default
would be to recommend
not to do that unless we
had a specific reason to.
So there's a little
bit of conversation
that needs to be had
when they're in that spot
and try to figure out
why they want to do that.
But generally, don't be
afraid to make projects.
We have customers out there
who have hundreds of projects.
And it's cool.
It all fits within
the reporting scheme.
It doesn't cost
anything additional.
So it's a nice, easy
divider there for you
to reflect those costs back.
The elephant here.
Multi-tenant systems.
And how do I use the tool sets
you've showed so far to reflect
back costs per customer?
And this is hard.
This isn't easy at all.
Oftentimes, it takes
a conversation about,
what's your architecture?
I see this and I assume
we have a GKE strategy.
But not everybody is there.
There's plenty of other
spots to be in for people.
Almost always, I'd say, let's
look at a labeling strategy.
The folder idea just
isn't going to apply here.
It's not going to
add a ton of value.
We might do both.
We might do both, depending
on how we're using GCP.
But labels are a better
way to dial in those costs.
Application level monitoring
is, of course, the best strategy
for the really large fish.
They'll be building in ways to
track how much each customer is
using all the different APIs,
do tracking back that way,
maybe look at transaction costs.
Probably look at a way to
monitor disk and storage usage.
So maybe fairly obvious,
but use the stack
that is friendly
for auto-scaling
so that the resources
can expand and contract.
That applies to everybody.
But multi-tenant
architectures need to do that.
GKE is by far the
most common choice
of how they choose to do that.
And then looking at monitoring
within the clusters.
I'm not going to get
into, how many GKE
clusters should we have here?
I know that's
super hotly debated
as to how big we go with that.
We know most people have
a namespace strategy
to try to isolate things.
We know we're getting more and
more comfortable with bigger
clusters.
But I wouldn't always assume,
let's go with one cluster
and shove everything into it.
That's not necessarily the plan.
It takes a bit of a
conversation about scale,
about, what are the
different services involved?
And almost always is a
whiteboard conversation for us.
So like I said, multi-tenant
cost alignment is very hard.
We've got a lot of tools
that can help you here.
New areas.
Monitoring services within
GKE to try to report back
what's happening at that level.
But in true
multi-tenant, we're still
going to have
customers all mixed
together, transactions
all mixed together.
And we need to really
build it in the app
to monitor what's
going on there.
So I think that's about
all at the high level
that we can give you on
the multi-tenant system.
It would be easy enough
to build some reports off
of this that help you see what's
happening at the service level,
for example.
So common recommendations
across the board that we have.
Automate provisioning.
Terraform is something
that comes up
every day in our world.
Provision things
programmatically.
And then we can
make sure they're
put in the right folders.
We can make sure they have
the right labels attached
and that the reports are
going to be accurate.
Another important recommendation
is start your folder design
with talking about IAM.
Don't start talking
about reporting.
We're approaching it
kind of backwards, then.
We need to make sure that
we're not using folders just
to report on consumption.
And then we have a less than
ideal identity access model.
We need to start by looking
at, what permissions
do we need to dial in per
folder before we talk about,
is that valuable as
a roll up for costs?
And a combination of labels
and folders is super common.
It's not like a this or that.
We can use both.
So like I mentioned,
I have some example
queries out there on GitHub.
Super big, long path.
We don't have a million
projects on our GitHub,
though, on our public GitHub.
So if you go to
GitHub.com/Agosto,
you'll see a script to go dump
out using G Cloud commands,
to dump out, what are my top
level folders and what are
their numbers?
And if I feed it
the right switch,
I can even generate
the insert syntax
to dump that into a
table in BigQuery.
So then the other
example queries
that I wrote have an
assumption that you're going
to have that table in place.
So I made the create
table statement.
I made several of the
required things to set it up.
And then you can
generate some queries
and see for yourself
what the data looks like.
And at that point,
hopefully, it's
usable as a building
block for you
to start creating
your own reporting.
Like I mentioned, I'll try
to add in this afternoon,
then, some links to the
template Data Studio reports.
Maybe start with the view
that I created in there.
You'll see one called View.
I don't remember exactly
the title of the file.
But it's a view.
And if you save
it as a view, you
can hook up Data
Studio to that, instead
of the billing data table.
And it will pull in your
folder names for you
that you can then use to filter.
So, hopefully, that's a
starting point for you
to start building some
of your own reporting
and be able to present
to your different people
within your business
what they need.
So from there, the
recommendation is always,
talk about who needs
to see this and try
to identify a couple
of different groups
within your organization
who need reporting.
And then start working with them
to see, what kind of exact data
do they need?
So we have those standard
Google Data Studio templates
that we work from.
And then we add
things all the time.
The first one we add is paid OS.
For anybody using paid
OSs, they need to see that.
So it's pretty easy
to see how that works
once you have the example.
So whether you're a
technical person like that
and want to dive
in, or whether you
want to give that
to someone else,
I think we have a
starting spot for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]